salut aujourd'hui on va se faire une
vidéo de colle de reading ya cinq ou six
personnes je crois qu'ils ont été
recrutés par loïc par famille et par
pierre je sais pas qui c'est je connais
pas leur nom je connais rien d'eux j'ai
essayé de gratter des infos mais n'ont
rien voulu me donner et on va essayer de
déduire des choses sur un peu qui sont
peut-être leur goût leur vie ce genre de
choses je vais pouvoir le faire en même
temps que moi alors forcément je vais me
planter plusieurs fois mais c'est ça
aussi le colza ligne il faut essayer de
faire des choses si vous savez pas
exactement ce que c'est cette
méthodologie le plus grand fier porter
c'est sherlock holmes qui faisait tout
par la déduction mais c'est un
personnage de roman non sherlock n'a pas
existé
arrêtez de croire ça mais ça reste quand
même le plus grand représentant de cette
méthode déductive juste en regardant les
gens donc dans un premier temps je vais
aller les voir je vais essayer
d'analyser des choses ils pourront pas
me parler mais ils pourront juste se
lever si je leur demande par exemple
pour essayer de voir un maximum de
détails sur eux mais surtout ne rien me
dire c'est chaud mais j'adore ce
challenge là j'espère que vous avez
apprécié cette vidéo essayer de prendre
des notes vocis sur vos spéculations
après on reviendra ici faire mes
hypothèses et après on fera les rives il
enverra sur quel taux j'ai bon et quel
taux jefo et à quel taux au comptant ou
adultes au jeu
je suis dégoûté du coup mais a light
maintenant c'est mieux loïc génériques
écoutez ça vu la forme et le ressenti je
pense que c'est un rideau promis que le
reading fait j'ai vraiment l'impression
d'être dans un truc de rencontre tournez
manège derrière le rideau il y a deux
personnes salut y avait un vrai truc
dans vos gardes on répond on répond pas
alors me répondait pas trop pour
l'instant me dit rien il faut juste que
j'en sache un peu plus sur vous mais
sans que vous me disiez quoi que ce soit
donc je vais me matter en fait c'est
très gênant n'est ce pas à tiens c'est
marrant il à la barbe bien taillée prend
soin de lui quand même et toujours
perdre un peu les choses sur l'état des
chaussures plusieurs des chaussures en
fait j'avais fait une vidéo sur leurs
colonies goût j'avais dit je regarde
toujours en priorité la tête
les cheveux les chaussures et également
les mains parce que ce genre de choses
dans un évidement qui peuvent traîner
des doigts peuvent être jeune quoi je
peux voir tes mains ce qu'il te plaît
c'est la satire est ce que j'ai bien
curé maisons en rangée ou quoi ok trop
cool déjà peu près vos âges aussi
forcément regarder du truc de
psychopathes en fait je regardais il y
avait des blessures des trucs c'est cool
hockey est ce que vous pouvez vous
mettre debout tous les deux et juste
debout
d'abord quand vous regardez de
plain-pied hockey est ce que vous pouvez
vous tourner
ok c'est juste pour voir si vraiment été
costauds situe simuler vous pouvez vous
rassure ok ça marche pour vous je
reviendrai pouvoir tout à l'heure mais
j'ai passé en salle numéro de voir mais
en tout cas sans avoir vu les autres je
sais déjà ces bruits meilleur
[Musique]
deuxième rideau est-ce que tu prends le
rideau ou est-ce que tu prends ce qu'il
ya dans la boîte
ça lui même pas trop le droit de me
parler mais vous avez le droit de me
répondre et de me dire des indices sur
votre agenda tenait non je rigole
ok merci d'être là trop cool
du coup je suis obligé de venir près de
vous deux vous observez et puis eux
aussi vous observe par cette caméra l'a
d'ailleurs et recrues qui déçoivent i
can soit fan de sailor moon race il est
un pote musculaire je peux regarder si
le droit tout regarder je vais vous dire
un secret de marketing non j'ai pas j'ai
pas le droit de merde de près le temps
de voir leurs prénoms
d'accord je vais pas lui je te jure je
les paye tu chantes tu te fais pas je
veux bien dire ce qu'il ya dessus ok
trop cool d'accord très bien parce que
tu peux te lever s'il te plait je
regardais mais c'est gentil de nous à
part dit puisque tu as des personnes qui
ont des lunettes de vue ok super style
juste et restera soir merci beaucoup
nous avons regardé également ce jeune
homme c'est quoi ta marquettois hockey
terre parce que ces geeks peut s'élever
s'il vous plaît cool je sais que c'est
très flou quelqu'un te regarde comme ça
te caresse la joue
je vais voir tes mains s'il te plaît
autant les toits non je regarde l'état
des deux musiciens de photos des petits
comme ça ok je te laissera soit très
chouette je vais passer là bas
[Musique]
et la troisième et dernière porte celle
de réunion excuse moi c'est pour la
réunion de recrutement s'est dit dans le
sud de la france
tu es monté sur scène le spectacle
d'accord ok mais j'ai pas ton prénom nom
donc vous ai déjà vu était monté sur
scène et on a fait en mode copilote tout
le long du spectacle
ok trop cool salut excuse moi je n'étais
pas parlé on ne sait jamais je pourrais
leur fils n'avait pas encore ses cheveux
extrêmement passionnant et intéressant
ok trop cool c'est en fait je suis ravie
d'un truc c'est que j'avais demandé à
loïc à pierre et à fanny de sélectionner
que des profils différents moi je ne
sais pas qui est là et vous êtes tous
des profils très différents et c'est
super est ce que vous demandez à tous
les deux vous lever s'il vous plaît de
vous lever
ok a trop bien
tiens s'est plaint d'un 10 et il avait
une consigne aussi c'était de s'habiller
comme tous les jours et pas exprès pour
le tournage etc
donc ça c'est chouette est ce que tu
peux tourner formidable tu peux te
retourner et me faire rare témoin ok
l'autre sens ok et c'est exactement
pareil si tu pouvais te tourner ça fait
très chaud ou un gsm et merci et de
retourner quand je suis fans d'alice moi
aussi tout à fait et me faire voir tes
mains et je vais approcher pour faire un
truc chelou c'est juste pour regarder ce
que tu as rome
c'est parfait
[Musique]
notre juste les petites impressions sur
tout là j'ai dit je pense est un truc de
seine je pense qu'il ya jean et je te
marier
pas sûr mais il a parlé de 6,4 et son
amour je pense qu'il sait que j'ai un
animal assez fière quand fêtes d'hérin
que au tee-shirt à la veste étant donné
que je serai vraiment dans temps le look
de ce qui va avec
ça doit y sentez rien car en regardant
mes mains et il savait certaines choses
moi je pense qu'il a trouvé un truc très
fort et un truc en tout cas et après que
le ballon j'ai l'impression qu'il est
perdu quand même pas lésiné ma
profession et c'est intéressant parce
que tu sens qu'il a fait ça que du coup
mon corps a tout donné sur un plateau
d'argent quoi donc c'était c'était tiens
voilà l'information
donc voila moi je pense qu'effectivement
il l'a trouvé pas mal de truc qui m'a
posé aucune question a fait référence à
l'iss
une petite chose donc je pense qu'il a
trouvé pas mal de trucs
du coup pour moi je ne sais pas trop il
sait pas beaucoup avancé mais
apparemment tout ce qu'il m'a dit c'est
qu'il avait une très bonne hypothèse
et du coup je pense que je fais griller
on verra bien ok ok pour moi
vous avez réuni tout le monde qui paraît
qu'il ya un challenge qui est prévu
pierre fanni et loïc qui viennent de
programmes ça donne je sais pas de
quelle vous êtes tous craignent allah
donc ok pour moi c'est ça le salon une
salle de hessel trois accords parce que
j'ai pris des notes
cela infâme informations que je pense
pour affirmer je pense pas ta vraie
couleur de cheveux alors c'est quoi le
challenge personnes connaissent ok
d'accord
donc il ya c'est bon je laissais jeu les
deux seuls qui m'ont regardé bas
quasiment en même temps en fait avant
tous les autres c'était un peu il
terminait te regarder en faisant avant
et tu m'a regardé direct et après il ya
une personne qui me regardait avec un
tout petit pic des cas la tchéquie me
fixe depuis que je les dis qu'il me
regarde et voilà bon alors qu'est ce que
j'avais comme comme petite hypothèse
hypothèses sur toi
déjà je pense que tu as 7 28 ans un peu
inventeront temps oui ok oui vous pouvez
dire thierry sauvage hockey arbh oui oui
d'accord est enchanté de te rencontrer
si je devais te te donner un prénom
spontanée je pense que je t'appellerai
je t'appellerai peut-être thomas ou
nicolas est-ce que c'est très éloigné ou
que s'approche tout comme le joli c'est
votre prénom ah oui ah oui mais on est
sur du prénom rares forcément waguet
bakou g10 27 28 ans paco signe
astrologique de discrétion et de respect
de travail de l'ombre d'autres fin
d'année je pense deuxième partie d'année
c'est correct tenait dans la deuxième
partie de l'année civile en cas d'accord
ok tu me rappelle mon frère donc comme
je vais pas mal me baser sur les
stéréotypes c'est ce qu'on fait souvent
durant le col reading faut faire
confiance au cias et stéréotypé pas de
tours a su réaliser mon frère et du 21
septembre
les balances je me demande si t'es pas
balance est ce que c'est bon mais c'est
passé grâce ionel en fait je dis tiens
il me rappelle donc j'avais fait une
vidéo aussi là dessus
qu'est-ce que je me suis dit oui par
rapport à tes mains bon on va oublier la
bague qui est trop étendue ouais voilà
ça trop visible je me suis demandé si tu
n'écris mais pas occulter ce n'est pas
obtenue pour le destin est ce que t'as
pas vraiment la poste de l'écrivain
et en même temps que dégage un truc
artistique non pas par le côté hipster
mais juste par exemple des grecs qui
sont bien assortis avec des chemises etc
pour moi ça me donne des indices la part
qui est relativement bien taillée mais
qui n'est pas non plus un mode je prends
soin de moi c'est juste pour pour avoir
quelque chose qui rende bien au regard
et ça c'est des trucs de dessinateurs
des traits de dessinateurs donc je me
demande si t'es pas dessinateur des
dessinateurs métier passion métier il un
but de troc aux logiques les deux trop
bien du coup je continue peut-être avec
avec toi si je devais te donner un
prénom
une sélection de hockey perm qu'est-ce
que j'en étais sûr car j'avais mis sur
mon métier c'est nice qui sait ni quand
tu respirer par le ventre et avait
vraiment une posture bien droites etc
et même quand tu parles tu projeter déjà
j'aurais opté pour chanteuse ou
peut-être comédienne mais je pense
chanteuse les deux lieux un métier où
passion ou utilisés par rapport à tout
ce que tu dégages et et cetera tutu à
tous les critères pour avoir quelqu'un
d'assez ouvert d'esprit qui fait des
voyages qui sort souvent de sa zone de
confort est ce que c'est bon ou pas oui
ok sur l'ensemble puis en soirée sur le
contact facile certains la zone de
confort voyages et tout ça trop cool et
alors pour le signe astrologique là
aussi j'avais une hypothèse t'as pas mal
de truc qui ressemble à moi et en
général on se reconnaît entre nous je
suis scorpions têtu scorpions en même
temps ses nerfs les c'est ok iachini
scorpio
prénoms des prêts nombre est bien prêt
non j'aurais dit tu es une aurélie ou
une amie aurélie emilie juillet après
non emilie elie qu'est-ce que j'ai
marqué sur toi emilie j'ai marqué geek
on se demande pourquoi
mais en vrai l'ensemble les geeks donc
je je je me demande si ton métier pas
dans l'informatique c'est aussi tout
simplement ça peu pareil hyper bus à
cause de ton t-shirt mais de là à
affirmer que ces métiers d'une personne
à j'avais mis par rapport à ta tenue
vestimentaire par rapport à ce que tu
dégages etc
je suis sûr que tu fais partie de ce
genre de personnes qui ont des passions
rares qui sont au-delà de gesté cinéma
où ceux ci cela que tu as des
populations plus atypiques pas forcément
non mais si c'est non c'est non moi et
toi tu as fait bof d'accord qu'est-ce
que jamie que tu dois avoir 22 23 ans je
vous dis je prends un vrai risque pour
les filières gé je me demande même si je
vais pas relevé cinq ans à chaque fois
juste pour abba oui j'ai pas dit du tout
lâche que je pensais que tu avais perles
je pense que tu as un peu un peu avant
30 ans 28 29 hockey pas écrit beaucoup
de choses en plus sur toi à part de da
manière d'être
même juste le fait d'être inscrits le
fait de l'avoir toujours le corps un
petit peu en avant d'être à l'écouté
tout et de gigoter en permanence être
pas selon moi un signe de stress qui est
plutôt un signe d'une personne de
romandie qui prend énormément
d'initiatives en fait qu'à pas peur de
faire des choses et tout prend des
risques et tout ça ça fait partie des
très terre-à-terre
ouais ok le dit oui ça fait elle avec un
t5
ok alors raphaël tu m'a posé souci
remets tes mains sur la table
en fait la manière dont tu tenais où tu
te n'était main et même la forme de tes
mains qui regardent ressemble vraiment à
la mienne
nous allons enfin au début je me suis
dit et peut-être musiciens mais t'as pas
du tout les doigts vouziers trop corner
etc et après me suis dit et notez
d'ailleurs il a un métier d'agilité ou
une passion de la visibilité au niveau
des doigts digital j'ai quand même noté
harpe ou magiciens magicien ouais non
non dommage oui plutôt plutôt métier
dhombres c'est à dire que je te vois
plus créatifs dans ton coin plutôt que
devant de la scène donc pas un métier de
contact direct genre unis vendeur ni sur
scène lire plutôt métiers indispensables
comme loïc derrière la caméra ou les
trucs comme ça le métier donc web en
effet je suis cadreur assistons c'est
vraiment cadreur presque un sétois il
s'agit de tact capricorne salutaire au
capricorne sagittaire sagittaire 1,6 et
planté qui a l'esprit d'initiative qui
peut avoir des passions atypique type e
se permet de lire moi en masse coupé non
correctes oui je pourrai connaître son
prénom potentiellement puisqu'on s'est
vu à rochefort du gard
donc je parle j'ai pas de prénom qui me
revient et je aucune tentative possible
c'est merci pierre c'est beaucoup qu'est
ce que j'aime izumi 22 23 ans 2 ans dans
dix jours
22 10 jours c'est tout à temps qu'est ce
que je sais moi je pense que tu es verso
personnellement on bombe alors un fort à
oui bon alors par rapport à ton tee
shirt etc
je pense que tu aimes la drogue une de
tes boisson préférée c'est la bière et
peut-être avant deuxième le whisky hier
celui de whisky thema tes doigts
bassiste exactement ok pas guitariste
c'est pas possible j'ai un prénom qui me
vient mais il pense être au mieux pour
toi je te rappelle isabelle rien à voir
c'est un prénom raoult patrice s'est
passé ok penser la première lettre de
ton prénom ça peut être là a peut-être
un bébé ça peut être un c d e f g h et
la bcz
w ah ah ah c'est ça on commence par un a
voilà c'est tout ce que je reste c'est
quoi ton prénom angie ça s'écrit amg
lieu à oui ou alors ça c'est vraiment
les profils comme les tiens mais c'est
pareil c'est très stéréotypé donc si
c'est pas ça tu ne m'en veut pas pas
m'en vouloir
c'est que des hypothèses je pense que tu
es capricorne par rapport à ton style
c'est encore une fois c'est toujours ça
collerait ding on part sur des
stéréotypes très basique à chaque fois
d'observation donc quand c'est pas ça
faut pas m'en vouloir mais par rapport à
ton style parce que tu dégages est
vraiment apte à tonio sancti mais at-on
pendentif à plein de choses aussi j'ai
pu voir sur tes gens d'un peu partout
sur toi je pense que tu est passionné
tatouage voir tatoueuse kat roots s'est
tatoué stato s'étaient installés et tout
est un cabinet trop cool où ça trop bien
fait ça c'est le problème des gens qui
ont un style très marqué c'est qu'après
je suis foutu delà de la base c'est pas
ça tu me tapes pas je pense que tu
approche la trentaine ou voire 30 ans
mais j'ai parti soit plus jeune et que
ce soit très désobligeant de dire ça
eh bien merci beaucoup d'avoir participé
si si vous avez une chaîne youtube ou un
instant que vous les mettre en avant je
le mettrais dans la description donc
checker la description je mettrai aussi
le site de tatouage dungey merci encore
mille fois à vous d'être venu ce n'était
pas forcément évident pour nous
d'organiser ça et pour moi de le vivre
parce que pour une fois je ne connais
rien de mon propre tournage qui voit là
ça va ça vous a plu c
trop cool merci beaucoup à vous je vous
like comme vous qui allez leaké cette
vidéo en tout cas si elle vous a plu ici
vous pouvez vous abonner
ici la vidéo de la semaine dernière ici
une vidéo mais extrêmement cool mais je
sais pas laquelle je mettrai à très
bientôt
ciao